listen to this song for a second okay
[Music]
when the evening sun goes down
we'll find me the nightlife the song
crazy nightlife and funny how time slips
away you wrote them all in the same week
in the 1950s this is around 1950 in the
same week that's right you were that
prolific or whatever yeah I was in a
pretty good writing place for sure what
makes a good writing place how come like
in one week what was going on in your
life that made it so easily you just so
focused on music I'm really you know I
was moving from Texas to Nashville I
wrote still working as a DJ yeah still
working as a DJ but I went to Nashville
to kind of break into the music yeah and
I wrote those songs on the way to
Nashville there's something about they
say driving a car I was just learning
about this over the weekend that it
turns off the left side of your brain so
driving things to be something that just
frees you creatively yeah yeah if I
really need and want to write a song
today and excuse me I'll get in the car
and take off driving down the highway in
any direction it doesn't matter and I'll
write a song isn't that amazing
yeah and so when you write three killer
songs like this in one week while you're
driving
that becomes hey that's my thing I'm
gonna go Drive take a drive and see what
comes out of me and you don't know where
these songs are coming from right they
just kind of appear out of nowhere oh
yeah are you a religious man probably
because I I would think when you're
driving along and you know that process
works and these songs come from nowhere
you might say well maybe it's like a
gift from God well for sure you know
what I'm saying like I don't know how I
conjure up these songs are you aware of
the inspiration that you know hit you at
that moment like you know the night life
I mean where does that come from what's
what's happening to you driving a car
yeah you never know for sure what
whether the song is any good or not
until you put it down listen to it and
but you know when you're driving my I
used to tell myself if I can remember
this till I get home and write it down
it'll be a good song so first of all I
love this song crazy just because it's
great but I like the history of it this
was a point in your life where of course
you taught that famous drive three songs
in one week and then suddenly is you
really were a songwriter at that point
trying to sell your songs to other
artists I went to Nashville to sell
songs because I had heard Nashville as
the store that's where you take your
brand it is and I went to Tootsie's
orchid lounge there in Nashville and
took a record of mine this particular
one you were playing with nightlife
right and crazy funny how time slips
away bring him by and you say anybody
want to buy a song well I put him on two
seas juice box there in Nashville right
now Patsy Cline's husband Charlie dick
and I were hanging out at Tootsie's
drinking beer and listening and I played
him that song crazy and he said Patsy's
got to hear this song he said let's go
play it for it was already midnight I
said well would ya okay we'll do it
tomorrow he said no come on and he went
to the house woke her up she come out to
the car made me go in and I played crazy
for and she loved it recorded it the
next week the legend was that she
thought it was too wordy or something
she tried to singing it she went to the
studio to record it and she tried
singing it and phrasing it the way I was
doing it and no one could do that the
producer said no you got to forget
Willy's phrasing you got to do it on
your own and she tried four days in a
row in the studio and she finally nailed
it